>> Tucker: NO COUNTRY IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE HAS FAILED
MORE COMPLETELY, VENEZUELA HAS A
LOT GOING FOR IT.
IT HAS A HUGE MIDDLE-CLASS, AND
TODAY IT CAN'T EVEN FEED ITSELF.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED, THEY
WERE OBVIOUS AND PREDICTABLE AND
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES BUT
THAT'S NOT THE WHOLE STORY OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
SIX YEARS AGO THE GOVERNMENT OF
VENEZUELA PASSED A GUN BAND
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO DISARM
THE PUBLIC.
THE POINT WAS TO MAKE THE PEOPLE
POWERLESS AND IT DEFINITELY DID
THAT.
AS ONE TERRIFIED VENEZUELA AND
PUT IT, PEOPLE NEVER WOULD HAVE
BELIEVED THEY NEED IS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT.
BUT OF COURSE, THEY DID.
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS ALMOST 200
PROTESTERS HAVE BEEN MURDERED BY
THE SECURITY FORCES OF DICTATOR
NICOLAS MADURO.
THE GOVERNMENT STILL HAS THE
GUNS OF COURSE, AUTHORITATIVE,
AUTHORITIES ARE NOT STUPID.
AND THAT PRINCIPLE APPLIES JUST
AS WELL TO THE UNITED STATES AS
IT DOES TO FAILING SOCIALIST
STATES.
LAWMAKERS THERE HAVE CHANGE THE
LAW TO ENSURE THAT IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO POLICE.
THEY KNOW LARGER MAGAZINES COULD
BE HELPFUL FOR DEFENSE WHICH IS
WHY THEIR BODYGUARDS STILL HAVE
THEM.
REGULAR CITIZENS HAVE TO FEND
FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS IS ON NYPD COMMISSIONER.
THERE ARE TWO PARTS, THE STATE
OF NEW JERSEY FOR A TIME MADE IT
A CRIME FOR ITS OWN OFFICERS
OFF-DUTY, INCLUDED OFF-DUTY, TO
HAVE MAGAZINES THAT I THINK HOLD
MORE THAN TEN ROUNDS.
WHAT WAS THE THINKING BEHIND
THAT?
>> HONESTLY IT WAS WORSE THAN
THAT.
THEY BASICALLY DID IT FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF NEW JERSEY, TEN
ROUND CAPACITY OR LESS, AND
ANYTHING ABOVE THAT IS A CRIME.
WHEN THEY DID THAT -- AND
BASICALLY IT WAS A CUNNING WAY
TO ATTACK THE LEGAL GUN OWNERS
BECAUSE, YOU HAVE 8 MILLION
HANDGUNS IN NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY.
YOU HAVE 2 MILLION ANTI-ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
NOT ASSAULT WEAPONS BUT
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS, RIFLES.
THEY HAVE CAPACITIES OF MORE
THAN TEN ROUNDS, AND THE
GOVERNMENT TOOK THAT AWAY AND
THEY HAVE TO ALTER THEM AND MAKE
THOSE GUNS USELESS.
WHEN THEY DO THIS, THEY ALSO
ADDED OFF-DUTY POLICE OFFICERS,
WHICH IS COMPLETELY BIZARRE.
AND IT'S ANOTHER ASSAULT ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY YOU HAVE
OFF-DUTY COPS AND MANY OF THEM
CARRY THEIR ON-DUTY WEAPON,
OFF-DUTY.
IF IT'S A 9-MILLIMETER AND IT
HAS AN MAGAZINE, 13 OR 14, THEN
IT BECOMES ILLEGAL.
IF HE IS HELD CRIMINALLY LIABLE,
YOU COULD BE HELD CIVILLY LIABL
LIABLE.
IT'S A MAJOR, MAJOR PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO GO BACK
TO SOMETHING YOU JUST SAID A
MINUTE AGO.
AND, YOU GO AFTER THE SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTING IT.
YOU WOULDN'T INTENTIONALLY
TARGET ILLEGAL GUN OWNERS WHO
ARE LIKELY TO BE LAW-ABIDING AND
IN FACT STATISTICALLY ARE LAW
ABIDING.
>> THAT'S ABOUT TAKING THE GUNS.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I COULD
THINK OF.
THESE ARE LEGAL LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN VETTED AND
THE BACKGROUND CHECKED, AND THE
GOVERNMENT DECIDED WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE EVERY MAGAZINE IN EXCESS
OF TEN ROUNDS, AND THAT'S A LOT
OF MAGAZINES.
>> Tucker: SO IF THAT IS YOUR
GOAL, YOU TAKE THE RESOURCES
FROM GOING AFTER, AND GO TO
LEGAL GUN OWNERS.
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT REDUCING
THE CRIME RATE, IS IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE BAD GUYS DON'T CARE ABOUT
YOUR GUN LAW.
AND THEY WILL HAVE MAGAZINES
THAT HAVE DOUBLE THE CAPACITY,
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
TO THEM.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PURPOSE WAS, AND THIS BROKE ON
THURSDAY OR FRIDAY WHEN THE
BERGEN COUNTY PROSECUTOR PUT OUT
A MEMO TO THE COP SAYING, BE
CAREFUL, BECAUSE OF THIS RULE OF
THIS LAW.
THEY REVISED A REVISION TO THE
LAW BUT THE GOVERNOR HASN'T
SIGNED IT.